[Music]
my name is juanita luke
i'm a second year mba student today is
my first day
starting the seed internship i'm really
really excited
i'm going to be working with almond
house in hyderabad india this is my
workspace today i'm actually in colombia
south america
what almond has does is that they
produce snacks
savory and desserts of indian types
my main project in almond house was
trying
and helping them develop go-to-market
strategies for
different countries that they're trying
to start a business in so they're trying
to investigate where to open new
businesses
we looked at a go-to-market strategies
for the us and for australia
right now i'm trying to partake in a
cultural activity from india
i actually ordered this delicious indian
food from an
indian restaurant here in colombia on
paris to
a native people from india i also
ordered typical typical food from
hyderabad
which is the biryani from a lamb
this looks amazing so i'm super excited
so i'm halfway through my internship and
i can say
it has been going really well i've had
great relationship
with the team in india there's great
report
and feedback i've been able to improve
the work that i'm doing
and i think it's gonna help them a lot
when i finish the internship i was able
to bring
impact to the people that i work with
with my coworkers during this
internship especially in the work style
so the way that i perform the work for
example starting with researching
competition then researching the the
customers then researching the trends
that sort of very very structured manner
i was able to teach the people there
how to do we could say a work plan in
such a short time
that brought a lot a lot of information
so i think
that from what i did and what i'm
handing out to them to my co-workers
they were able to have like that
different
work experience or the different sort of
project planning
and projects execution that's different
from what they have now
i was able to learn from my co-workers
to be we could say a little bit less
structured we could say shift my
timeline
so i was able to learn a lot of that
from them
while they were able to learn like this
organization structure for me
i wanted to ask you can you talk about
your favorite part of working with me as
an intern
your contagious positivity that you
bring to the
conversation openness to taking feedback
the willingness to learn
and you've demonstrated those skills
extremely well
it's really encouraging to have worked
with you
what i learned in the seed internship
that i think
will impact me is working with different
cultures so different
and similar to my own being able to
adapt
and learn from these cultures that is
going to help me
as a professional any situation i go
being able to see the impact that you
can have in a company
and in this society it's something that
i wouldn't have experienced
if i did any other internship in the
world i think
this opportunity that stanford is giving
us it's something that
we have to take into advantage because
we we have
this we could say privilege of helping
others
in countries that are so amazing that we
might not have the ability to
see in other situations
you